[Music]
hello there
fortnight chapter 2 season 6 has given
us an insight into the secret story
behind the island we call home
from the foundation's arrival to agent
jonesy's betrayal and everything in
between
i'm looking at you raz as season seven
arrives now's the time for the ultimate
season six story recap so sit your butt
down for 10 minutes
and let's relive primal fortnite oh and
uh code adamaru in the store
pretty please battle pass new season
okay a quick note that i won't be
talking about batman in this video i
have a full series on that sub
story right now all i want to cover is
the core story
inside the game to do that we actually
need to go back to season five
to set the scene the season in which
jones was sent into the loop to prevent
any of us from leaving the item he
brought here is actually the key to
everything that portal device let agent
jonesy open rifts in time and space
to gather the greatest hunters and
fighters from multiple dimensions
this took a toll on the zero point and
by the end of the season
it was going to collapse this also
coincides with jonesy
losing all faith in the organization he
once devoted his life to
i've dedicated my life to the order i've
given everything
and for what to just sit back and watch
reality end
that's not who we are at least it's not
who i
am the order removed all jonty's
security privileges
as he wanted to learn more about the
seven i mean who doesn't want to know
more about the seven
this was the end for agent jones who
took matters into his own hands
during the zero crisis event returning
to the island one last time
john d talks to a new character in the
series dr sloane overcomes
at this point we still don't know dr
sloane's place in the story
the zero point isn't floating we've lost
control save yourself
if i don't stop this it could destroy
all existence
you have your orders now get out of
there i'm gonna do what we should have
done from the very start
i'm going to the seventh you took it out
dr sloan attempts to dissuade jones from
his actions but i think this time it's
safe to say
he has completely abandoned io
jones is now in full 80s action hero
mode destined to get to the zero point
avoiding hunters and warriors and even a
cameo from tian tina
and not a single one of them can stop
him here's the science
jones uses the portal device to bring
the founding member of the seven
to the island
come on come on
luckily the impact of this meteor didn't
cause a divot the size of a small town
like in chapter one
inside the meteor is a very disgruntled
foundation who immediately sees an io
agent as the enemy
but even a hulking great rock of a man
can be humbled
by words
i can get you to jenna jenno something
about this
is important but yet again we don't know
what this is it could be a person
it could be a planet maybe it's that
planet there but wait there's more
and the sisters i can get you all of
them
but i need your help to fix that
jones will give the seven all they want
in return
for containing the zero point and
surprisingly
the foundation agrees first giving back
the portal device to jaunty before the
pair work together to close the rips in
the fabric of time
each plume of energy scorching the land
beneath their feet
but this attempt to save reality is
failing it's not enough
i can't stop it but i might be able to
contain the blast
you must be stealing yourself you don't
have to do this
the foundation seals himself into the
zero point by overloading the portal
device
but each of these actions have dire
consequences
the foundation is now stuck inside the
zero point
and agent johnsy is now stuck
permanently in the loop
no matter what happens do not give up
i will find you and you will tell me
everything
you have my word here
we go
upon waking we remain stuck in the loop
with everyone else but the world has
changed from the scorches the zero point
left behind
these were primal time flares taking
parts of the island
back to the prehistoric era
this new world gave us new people to
speak to and a few are very important
we'll get to rasoon first his sister
tarana is our conduit to understanding
the world we now share
her ability to analyze and understand
ancient artifacts
helps us understand the spire and this
mythical energy it has
out of nowhere tirana offers us a
strange device
but in return she requires a few fetch
quests
once we've done that there's another
bump in the road the device was stolen
and that's when we finally meet raz he
stole the device from his own sister
and acts like that's a normal thing to
do raz is revealed to have studied the
ancient spire for his
entire life and yearned to control the
power it hides
but he's also a nice guy and he gives us
the strange device
which so happens to be an audio log have
a listen
[Applause]
listen to the crystal song and by the
sounds of it that must have been agent
jones
we found the crystals they were located
at the spire hidden in the walls
but to take them we needed a disguise an
alias
which we take from the spire guardians
who were found at the five outposts
it turns out each of these guardians
holds an i
o medallion so somehow the spire
guardians are io agents
too whether they know it or not is a
question for another time
next we return to those five mini spire
outposts and realized by using an
energy converter we can hear the
foundation even though he's locked
inside the zero point
he has two words for us
jones knows we all thought we know what
that meant and agent jones who left the
imagined order but heck no
this meant a jones stuck in the loop the
problem was
there were so many of them it was hard
to know which jones is the best to ask
so off we trot speaking to all the
joneses we could find on the island
from castaway jonesy to scuba jonesy
from jonesy the cabbie to bunker johnsy
they all gave us info some were useless
but some gave us a real insight into the
loop
cabbie jonesy says me working with the
foundation
not likely that guy is just itching for
an excuse to kick
my weight how do you know about the
foundation also how do i know about the
foundation
the loop does strange things to your
memory many of the other jones snapshots
share a similar story arriving at the
island with a specific mission in hand
but then that soon fades away and they
become shells of their former selves
but wait there's another jaundi on the
island to speak to
jonesy the first the first guy to ever
jump out of the battle bus
back in 2017 he's now living it up
in pleasant park and doesn't trust us at
all when we start asking questions
luckily he likes a good scrap and by
dueling him
he gives us more information there are
people who think the spire will make
them powerful
it will but it will exploit their every
weakness
i wonder who he's talking about it has
to be razz his obsession with the spire
is so dedicated he gave up his entire
life to study it
and those runes he's even happy enough
to steal from his own sister to
understand the spire more
but wait there's even more to this do
not allow the spire to corrupt
someone powerful or jones does not stand
a chance
go now before the spire attracts any
more attention from the
and he just stops talking damn it jonesy
does he mean io the imagined order does
he mean another invasion from a passing
galactus
we just don't know just yet the
following week this premonition came
true
raz went to the spire and made it his
home immediately becoming volatile and
corrupted
attacking anyone who ventured near the
spire the power he now holds
is amazing his health pool is endless
and should we get too close
raz can take our life force thanks to
that artifact
it's safe to say raz is corrupted just
like johnsy said
jones tells us to defeat raz and take
away that artifact to prevent him from
becoming all-powerful
which we do because we're badasses like
that but now
look at what this artifact is it's a
shard of kevin the cube
the magical cube that is now entwined in
our law
we always thought kevin would return one
day but we never know how
and now we possess a tiny amount of that
energy force
looking at razzy's backbling i think we
know what he wants to do
bring back the storm king the original
version of the cube from save the world
who also invaded the center island
before raz does look to be a follower of
the storm king
[Music]
it now appears as if we were too late to
disarm raz and jones's prediction was
right
especially this bit go now before the
spire attracts any more attention from
the
well i thought he was going to say io
but in fact the attention he spoke of
is actually an alien invasion as i'm
saying this
in game many people are being abducted
by aliens and after a quick probe
they are returned to the island in
movies aliens do this to claim our
memories and understand our biology
but here's the thing what will happen
when the aliens take jonezy the first
or raz as the last few days of the
season pass by
we can find cb radios around the island
which when interacted with
will link to an alien calling show of
sorts in which people discuss
extraterrestrials there's even dennis
from save the world in there
good touch crop circles have appeared in
the fields and mysterious television
screens are ready to show us the next
step in this journey
so grab your popcorn and enjoy this ride
my guess is that the alien race are
those who created kevin the cube
and the alphabet of markings that we see
on the runes they do look alien in
origin
and now after all these years the aliens
have returned
thanks to the spires creation and
razzi's meddling are they here to pass
judgment maybe to enslave us or is this
another one of io's misdirections to
keep us in the loop
we find out more in season seven i'm
adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome
i'll see you in season seven
[Music]